hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
um october 26 2020 what's going on how
are you
now the first thing you probably noticed
and it's just like well bill you know
what
i'm not hearing the energy that i'm used
to
i'm not hearing the light i'm not
hearing the positivity i mean here we
are we're rolling into the holidays
and you're coming with this glum tone i
kind of [ __ ] up my voice
uh as i mentioned last week i got caught
up i was four episodes behind with
episode family and i
recorded uh last week on tuesday and
wednesday and knocked out four episodes
of screaming like frank murphy so
forgive me
my voice is a little rough here so i got
the throw coat tea
i finally learned how to drink tea
you know i used to pour it on my leg no
um i drank it like a [ __ ] american
the water was piping hot and the bag was
still in the [ __ ] cup and it finally
dawned on me that the heat
because i always hated like coffee and
tea i'm like it's too [ __ ] hot
it burns my mouth it just tastes like
dirty water
scalding dirty water why why would i
why would i want to do this right
and then the other day i finally
actually used my brain it's like
the hot water is to activate whatever
the [ __ ] in the tea bag
and then you take the tea bag out of the
thing it's so funny that
bag has just become like a sexual thing
there's an actual tea bag
then you take it out of the cup you
throw it away and by then the [ __ ]
the it's drinkable and it's actually
enjoyable
so i like to apologize to everybody in
england all these years i've been making
fun of [ __ ]
sitting around drinking tea i get it
it's way better than coffee
i would say i'm not a big coffee ah
jesus why why would you do that bill
you're already [ __ ] all over golfers
in uh on the bill bart podcast
you know people all up in arms with that
[ __ ]
activity i stand by it it's not a sport
it's an activity if you're an athlete
you will excel at it more so
than the average jerk-off out there
without a doubt
um you know
i mean that's that's like anything
that's like you're sitting at your desk
and you [ __ ] throw a
[ __ ] piece of paper into a waste
paper basket man is that is that a
[ __ ] sport
i don't know no my difficulty with with
golf
especially with all the [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know sports fans who just sit there
and they talk about cheating
with the astros or the patriots or
[ __ ] whatever you know big college
programs
they talk about cheating and it's just
like oh yeah what about you and your
golf score
huh with your mulligans and your
breakfast balls
and your gimmies you know
and that [ __ ] whatever you're
supposed to stick your arm out and drop
it
you sort of kick it with your foot or
whatever the [ __ ] you do that caddyshack
[ __ ]
um it's a dishonest sport played by
dishonest people
uh who you know
i don't know i don't i just i just like
[ __ ] on it
these [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know every [ __ ] two weeks my
[ __ ] my my friends
with this stupid [ __ ] game golf beer
oh dude i got my new drive oh dude i got
this new set of wedges
it's just like every [ __ ] year every
two years they gotta go out
and get a brand new set of clubs they go
into these [ __ ] stores
right and they analyze your swing
and if you're hooking or if you're
slicing they like twist the clubs so you
you don't have to improve as a player
the club adjusts to your [ __ ] swing
that's just like i mean and you're gonna
get on the astros for banging on a
[ __ ] trash can
i have no idea speaking of that my
internet's all [ __ ] up of course
let's see here yeah why would you load i
only paid nine million dollars a month
for [ __ ] everything
i couldn't believe it i was talking to a
buddy of mine yesterday who's older than
me
and he's a cord cutter it's just like
holy [ __ ]
you know what he got a [ __ ] 19 year
old girlfriend now what are you what
what are we doing here um
let me see here i want to look up uh who
won last night
the dodgers were looking to go up three
games to one i've been watching that
series man
unbelievable game on uh friday holy
[ __ ]
it's three games to two the dodgers won
last night oh so the rays must have tied
it up oh i forgot they played every
single night i watch friday night i miss
saturday
um oh wait did the raise win saturday
wait a second that back and forth game
because i had to leave right at the end
so it's three games to two oh my god can
you imagine if the [ __ ] dodgers lose
it again this year
jesus christ
i don't know i like both teams though i
just think it's gonna be cool for la or
for tampa bay that they win two
championships in one year
and i gotta tell you the greatest
[ __ ] thing you can do as
a sports fan is be happy for other
people's championships i
the sheer joy of just watching sports is
ruined by your hatred
of your rivals
you know like look i'm never going to
root for the [ __ ] canadians the
yankees the lakers
or whatever but i mean if they win a
championship they won the championship
so what good is it
for me to sit here and waste all this
energy
resenting it ain't good for them
good for them they won a championship
fantastic i hope it happens for us next
year but i'm not going to [ __ ] be mad
at your championship congratulations
that's great
and then you know what else it does it
annoys the fans of the other team so it
actually works
but back to the tea everybody back to
the tea
oh i'm a you know i'm not a big tea
drinker
you know i'm not gonna lie to you i i
never get
that one of the smart [ __ ] things i
did for all the time i've wasted
um watching sports no and i've
i've wasted a lot of time um in fact
this whole [ __ ] weekend
this whole weekend i just decided i
wasn't gonna do [ __ ]
all right i watched uh
i got all caught up on motogp although i
didn't watch yesterday's race i you know
comes on too [ __ ] early and i was
waiting for him to upload the race to my
my stupid um
internet isn't working here and i'm
hoping dude if alex mark has won a race
i mean i'm so
i'm excited to see who's gonna win the
championship this year all right but the
king mark marquez
is hurt right so what are you gonna do
it is what it is so next year it's like
those two houston rocket championships i
mean michael wasn't playing
he wasn't playing the first year and
then the next year he was he was getting
his legs back
um oh they're not going to lick me in
houston with that one um
but next year to see both marquez
brothers
both riding hondas competing against one
another
and then watching their dad freaking out
is just gonna be it's gonna be amazing
it's gonna be amazing i can't i'm
already looking forward to next season
but i'm telling you
that's where it's at that's where racing
is at because i actually watched a
little bit of the formula one race
yesterday uh it happened to be on i
turned it on
uh about 20 laps in
and it was just more the same lewis
hamilton out in front no one's going to
pass him you already know he's going to
win the race with 40 laps to go um
all the racing is going on for like
fifth sixth seventh place like that's
where you want the camera to be
um and that's what happens a lot of
those [ __ ] races like they won't show
lewis for like [ __ ] four laps because
he's so far ahead of everybody
but it is what it is the guy's the
greatest driver ever but it's he's so
much better
and mercedes is so much better than
everybody else that it's just [ __ ]
boring um
it's like watching the nba with like
pylon teams oh
bill can't you just be positive so
anyway i watched um i got caught up with
that
and um i also uh i watched indiana
versus penn state
holy [ __ ] what a game that was
it was funny i text my buddy in the
middle of it when penn state came back
like you knew they were going to
and i texted him i was like why does why
does the university of indiana have a
football team
because i'm always rooting for them
every year it seems like they're going
to upset ohio state or penn state or
michigan or somebody [ __ ] big
you're in there you're watching the game
and then like if the game was
three-quarters long
indiana would be [ __ ] big ten
championships
so i'm watching him blow it right
penn state scores a [ __ ] touchdown
minute and a half left indiana's not
gonna score
right so we're [ __ ] just sitting
there
talking about them like that
it's like it's like watching charlie
brown trying to kick the football and
all of a sudden indiana goes down the
god damn field
scores a touchdown to win it
not to win it sorry to tie it up to go
into overtime right
so then penn state gets the ball of
course and they drive right down the
field and get a touchdown i was like ah
well at least at least
you know indiana turned the corner they
turned the corner and they were able to
at least not lose it until [ __ ]
overtime and then they marched down the
field not only scored the touchdown have
the balls
to go for the two-point conversion
and uh who knows people might dispute it
or whatever but there was that was ruled
the touchdown the
nose of the ball could have gone across
before touched out of bounds and then
hit the corner pylon
[ __ ] amazing amazing game
congratulations to the university of
indiana
my condolences to penn state because um
you know you guys losing to indiana is
actually just good for ohio state
and for some reason i mean ohio state
drives me up the [ __ ] wall
i really like the team but their fans
are just
the biggest whining [ __ ] babies every
year they think that they should be in
the playoffs
the amount of times they've whined and
actually got in the playoffs only to
lose by
40 [ __ ] points in the first round
sec can't play with us you know
i'm not saying that you know i mean some
years they do but every year they think
that
you know some years they are better i'm
not saying that but like you know
not saying they're not but like the
amount of times they whined and cried
and got in there
and then the whole country had to
[ __ ] sit there and watch a terrible
[ __ ] football game
um i don't know
i got issues with them and one year they
they won somehow they won the big
the big ten championship over [ __ ]
penn state who had like a better record
and beat them it was something [ __ ]
insane like that
and they still [ __ ] whine and cry or
maybe it's just the ones that i know
i have no idea i shouldn't paint that
brush i just said that i was letting go
of all of that [ __ ] right
anyway sorry uh so i watched that and
then i just watched a bunch of pro
football
uh yesterday i watched the the
pittsburgh steelers
who are looking [ __ ] uh looking great
who
there's some great names by the way in
uh
in sports right now cd lamb
and uh who's uh juju smith
schuster
the whole game i kept going throw it to
juju smith shuster
let's one of him say that name again
then there's a guy in the [ __ ] um
i watched the uh i had the first half of
the alabama tennessee game
i'd look the guy's name it's like henry
oyo oyo or something [ __ ] crazy like
that
let me find this guy tennessee it's one
of the best [ __ ] names
there was some good ones when i was
growing up billy joe robido
buck baloo all right tennessee
falls
is it henry or is it hair oh it's henry
it literally just came up
henry it's t o apostrophe o
t o apostrophe oh two toe oh oh oh or
something i can't even i don't
i don't know how to say it i'm gonna get
the pronunciation whatever whatever
watch the game
i was watching to play alabama which
it's just like you know
you only need to watch the first half of
a [ __ ] alabama game
it's like their entire team is like
number one draft picks for the [ __ ]
nfl
i mean the tennessee couldn't even
[ __ ] tackle them they were just
running through them
so i just watched the first half of that
that's right then i switched over to
indiana penn state so anyway
um i watched the um the pittsburgh
steelers uh
sort of handled the titans titans came
back a little bit there but they just
sort of [ __ ] handle them and i saw
one of the best collisions
at the goal line i forget the guy's
[ __ ] name
met derrick henry just blasted through
the line it
was sort of i mean i don't want to
exaggerate but jack tatum earl campbell
old school kind of football um he got up
claiming he hurt his shoulder my buddy
said that that's what they do when they
get a concussion they just claim it's a
[ __ ] shoulder
um but i enjoyed the hell out of that
game
and i was also watching a little bit of
the uh
the cleveland browns and the bengals
to you know young stud quarterbacks
there
and baker me uh mayfield and uh joe
burrow
and uh baker mayfield five [ __ ]
touchdowns
and the one in the late you know what's
great
is uh my boy
colin cowherd is still dying on that
hill with baker mayfield he just won't
give it up to him
he won't give it up to him uh so that's
sort of the game within the game
is um i like baker mayfield and i i want
to see him be successful because i want
to see
uh i want to see his next appearance
on the great colin cowherd show i just
want to see
how that plays out if they can
eventually just sort of you know become
friends
you know like the end of a sitcom
episode um
but anyways congratulations to them i'm
telling you the i know i know cleveland
got to live and [ __ ] kicked at him by
the uh
the steelers last week but um
dick other than that game that games are
[ __ ] that that's an exciting
fun [ __ ] team to watch as are the
bengals even though they don't have a
great record or whatever they're just
they're
in games and i think you're seeing um
especially with joe burrow like uh
that guy is gonna be like i'm really
looking forward to him at
them building a team around that guy and
then seeing him going up against patrick
mahomes you know i'm thinking maybe
that's like the afc
gonna be qb rival there there's so many
great young quarterbacks coming up
and i think uh you know when i was a kid
in the afc i would watch you know in the
80s it was elway and moreno
and then out west what was it it was joe
montana
and uh it's kind of just joe montana
[ __ ] guy was winning all the time um
what the hell were the quarterbacks in
the 80s out there
do you know what i can't even think of
anybody that really stands out
randall cunningham eagles had uh
phil sims sorry the giants had
phil sims redskins after
joe namath i'm sorry joe theismann was
doug williams
who else was in that division
jim hart was out then it was neil lomax
i know i know i can't remember oh
speaking of that oh i watched a great
[ __ ] movie yesterday my wife was
getting so sick of me watching sports or
whatever i love my wife i want to hang
out with her i said you know what i
stumbled across this movie i want to
check it out
it's called badlands
starring martin sheen and
[ __ ] spacek and i got to tell you
you watch that you're like oh now i see
where true romance came from
and it was based on this [ __ ] serial
killer
let me look this up here sorry i don't i
gotta do it on my phone here badlands
1973.
uh let me see here it was based off of
this [ __ ]
guy who went on this this rampage
um he killed like [ __ ] 11 people
he killed like 10 of them in like two
days he went on this rampage and when he
got arrested
you know he had a girl you know
girlfriend [ __ ] she was with them
she claimed that you know he forced her
to do [ __ ] or whatever so
she got 17 years he got the [ __ ]
electric chair
and um the guys
murders were [ __ ] brutal
i mean as most murders are but just like
you know
old people kids just horrible [ __ ]
and but this kid looked like james dean
people said
so it was the first time people sort of
got enamored
by image you know tv was young this is
the 1950s when the [ __ ] went down
and um i got to get you the [ __ ]
guy's name here so you can look this
thing up
but the most amazing thing was was as
all like you know
you know the broads they love a bad boy
so they [ __ ]
they're sitting there going nuts for
this kid and the cop who pulled who like
one of the cops that arrested him
actually knew who the guy really was
beyond just being like a murderer right
a serial killer piece of [ __ ]
he said when they were shooting at him
they shot his windshield and the glass
went into his face
and he pulled over because he thought he
was bleeding to death and the cops said
cause that's the kind of yellow son of a
[ __ ] he was
and i was like there it is there's the
truth of the guy
he's out there [ __ ] killing kids and
old people and just just all these
innocent people
you know walking around like he's just
[ __ ]
you know i don't know what and then he
gets a little glass on his face
like oh my god i'm bleeding to death
take me to a hospital
um what is his [ __ ] name god damn it
all right
badlands i really appreciate you guys
sitting through this badlands
serial killer
based on here we go here we go
no charles stark weather
that's what it is charles stark weather
listen to this [ __ ] [ __ ] all right
mug shot not a good mug shot
um looks like a dick tracy character but
you know back then people weren't good
looking
as they as good looking as they are
today because with
with each cycle we keep getting more and
more mixed up with each other and it
just
i don't know it just works if you notice
that you know
it's very rare that you get like a
[ __ ] i always look at the royal
family you know they've been all
[ __ ] banging each other for hundreds
of years and they're all weird looking
um all right charles raymond
charlie starkweather was an american
spree killer
who murdered 11 people in nebraska and
wyoming between december 1957 and
january 1958 this [ __ ] guy was
killing somebody like every three days
uh when he was 19 years old he killed 10
of his victims between
january 21st and january 29th
if you're doing the math at home that's
eight days he killed ten people
this guy was doing two a days like he
was [ __ ]
playing texas football here uh january
21st and january 29 1958 the date of his
the date of his arrest during his spree
in 1958
stark weather was accompanied by his 14
year old girlfriend
carol ann fugate
um just out of curiosity is she still
alive
is she this the woman's she's still
where the [ __ ] is she today my god
um still alive but i mean she was 14.
what i don't know what are you going to
do
bourne stark weather both starkville and
fugate were convicted on charges for
their parts in the homicides
starkweather was sentenced to death and
executed 17 months after the events
few gates served 17 years in prison
gaining release in 1976
stark weather's electrocution by
electric chair in 1959 was the last
execution
in nebraska until 1994 when the people
of nebraska demanded the return of
capital punishment
they don't [ __ ] around out there um
all right her relationship with care his
relationship caroline
1956 the 18 year old stark weather was
introduced to 13 year old carol anne
fugate by her older sister
whom he had previously dated there's
just going to be nothing normal in this
story people
he dropped out of lincoln high school in
his senior year and was working at
western union newspaper warehouse
he sought employment there because the
warehouse was located near whittier
junior high
high school in lincoln where fugate was
a student
giving his working schedules
starkweather began to visit caroline
fugate every day after school
he was considered a poor worker his
employees later recalled sometimes you'd
have to tell him something two or three
times
of all the employees in the warehouse he
was the dumbest man we
had i love old school
quotes they just [ __ ] say what the
[ __ ] they're thinking
uh starkweather taught fugate how to
drive and one day she crashed his 49
ford into another car however
starkweather's father
guy was right was a registered owner of
the vehicle
he paid the damages but argued with his
son about it
and his having let his unlicensed
girlfriend drive
refusing to condone his son's behavior
guy banished stark weather from the
family home
the young man quit his job at the
warehouse and became a garbage collector
for minimum wage
he began to develop a nihilistic
worldview
is that when the sun goes around you uh
refers to a number of different views of
philosophy all of which express some
form of
negation towards common philosophical
concepts such as
knowledge existence or the meaning of
life different forms of needles
all right i guess i'm never going to
know what that word means um
a nihilist a nihilist on a nihilistic i
thought that meant you you're sort of
self-involved
you didn't give a [ __ ] about other
people i don't know he used his time
on the garbage route to begin plotting
bank robbers robberies he settled on a
personal philosophy by which he lived
the remainder of his time uh
dead people are all on the same level
that was his philosophy whatever the
[ __ ] that meant all right first murder
late
november 30th 1957. starkweather became
angry at robert
colvert a service station attended in
lincoln for refusing to sell him a
stuffed animal on credit
he returned several times during the
night to purchase
small items until finally brandishing a
shotgun he forced culvert to give him
dollars from the tilt he drove covert to
a remote area
where they struggled over the gun
injuring covert before starkweather
killed him with a shot to the head
all right and he's off then
doesn't do [ __ ] for like a month um
two months actually on january 21 1958
stark weather went to fugate's
home to get his girlfriend fugate's
mother and stepfather velda and marion
bartlett told him to stay away
he fatally shot them then strangled and
stabbed
yeah their granddaughter you don't want
to hear this this is just it just gets
worse
just check out the [ __ ] movie it's
[ __ ] brutal
i mean at the mo the movie okay what
this guy actually did
is [ __ ] brutal the movie um
the movie basically there's so many
movies that
when you watch badlands from 1973
starring martin sheen and [ __ ] spacek
my movie pick of the week um
there's so many movies that uh
you see that relationship um
there's a brad pitt movie uh california
there's um i always forget the name
i just had the [ __ ] name of it the
oliver stone movie
one there with the natural-born killers
true romance um
the whole style of the movie the music
the narration over you know reminded me
of uh
some of the stuff i saw in the 80s and
90s and stuff very influential
movie badlands uh
check that out 1973. if you can't if you
have the time
if you have the time it looks like
everybody's sort of back to work at this
point
um speaking of which everybody
you would you guys like to hear my
presidential election picks
picks picks picks i
i voted i did the whole thing i stuck in
one of those yellow boxes near the
library
praying to god somebody wouldn't [ __ ]
come by and just
praying to god it was a real one or
whatever um
all right so here's my presidential
picks
presidential picks my presidential pick
here my thing is this
do not listen to these stupid [ __ ]
polls
the polls are not accurate all right you
got to understand what's going on here
here's the deal conservatives are
conservative they consider it rude if
you ask them who they're voting for so
they just say they're undecided
right liberals can't shut the [ __ ] up
about who they're voting for so it's
never going to be accurate
liberals all they want to do is tell you
who they're voting for and how you
should be living your life
right conservatives on the other hand
they keep their [ __ ] mouth shut
while they secretly plot all of their
[ __ ]
so there you go it's not a poker game
here
well i guess it is but one person's
saying what they have
the other person is not saying they
might have garbage i don't know what i
have no idea what's going to happen but
i will say
that uh oh well the orange dum-dum
did himself a service by actually
behaving like a [ __ ]
adult i mean i didn't really watch it
but from what i saw he wasn't like
interrupting
i just love that they have them on a
split screen now so you can like look at
both of their reactions i call it the
trump camp
i don't ever remember them doing that i
thought they always just
they put it on the person maybe they
always did i have no idea
um so anyway don't listen to those
stupid [ __ ] polls i remember the last
time they were like ah hillary's gonna
[ __ ] trounce him
he's gonna [ __ ] trounce him it's like
no
no liberals just said who they were
voting for and conservatives don't i
mean how many times can you [ __ ] fall
for this
um so we shall see
you know i just look at it this way
worst case scenario
i'm halfway done with this [ __ ] guy
um and i have to be honest with you a
lame duck
donald trump that is a scary scenario
what the [ __ ] is he that guy could do a
lot of damage in a month
um but we shall see we shall see all
right with that
with that but you know what good luck to
both people running you know like i said
i'm done
i'm done giving a [ __ ] and getting all
[ __ ] emotional
about this [ __ ] all right if half the
country wants a scarecrow with the
facelift
he'll be the president if the other half
likes a [ __ ] race-baiting
[ __ ] i don't know what the hell he is
then i guess we'll have that guy
but you know what there's nothing i
could do about it
so let's just continue reading about
syracuse what the [ __ ] is my goddamn
email
christ i just had it
i'm on the wrong app here i'm sorry guys
i just it's just
there's just never going to be a day
when i [ __ ] get this [ __ ] right
all right i had it i had what i needed
it was right here at the top
am i the only guy getting like nine
million [ __ ] emails from donald trump
was like did i [ __ ] vote for this guy
what is going on here
um all right let's do the live reads
here's oh
look who it is everybody do me undies me
undies
liberals can't shut their mouths to do
do do me undies my undies conservatives
live in the south
they got long driveways and they keep
their mouths shut
you don't know who they're voting for
and then trump wins and they strut
they think it's great cause he's gonna
make it better the way it [ __ ] used
to be
would black people couldn't go to their
schools all right
me undies everybody hi friends uh
meundies believes that comfort is about
more than what's touching your skin
it's about feeling comfortable in your
skin you're a total badass
and what you wear should only accentuate
that fact
[Laughter]
i don't want to be a jerk but you're not
a total badass a badass is a badass this
whole [ __ ] thing where like i'm a
warrior you're not a warrior
you're not a warrior you're afraid to
get into a physical confrontation that's
not a warrior
all right meundies truly ex believes in
empowering
self-expression oh that's exactly what
we need to do me undies let's let's
inflate people's egos even more
um how about an overall humbleness
with humanity and and we start to learn
how we should be interacting with
nature rather than trying to grab it by
its throat and make it do what it
what we want it to do like we're going
to win that fight uh
their pledge for 2020 and beyond is to
is called me undies
gives an initiative that supports those
who have systematic barriers to their
self-expression
you talking about fat people by shopping
me und
you support causes oh such as lgbtq
plus oh [ __ ] lgbtq
plus that's like when you get disney
plus right that's not just disney that's
all the extra [ __ ]
uh oh plus community sorry mental health
and well-being in women's rights
why does that all seem redundant those
are all okay those are the that's the
mount rushmore of [ __ ] that we're paying
attention to not one thing in there
about mother nature
none of those groups are going to exist
with global [ __ ] warming you know
what are we doing here
let's big swirl of trash out in the
pacific ocean there's probably [ __ ]
undies there's tighty whities floating
around there because everybody's buying
me undies
me undies offers classic colors to
ridiculous prints
it's all so you can fully express
yourself in your own unique way myani's
believes that you
and your butt deserve comfort inside and
out well you got to agree with that
which is why they created the meundies
membership it's really just a great way
to love on yourself
each month replenish your basics with
styles
that are anything but basic styles that
let you get to be the truest version of
yourself right down to your core
plus enjoying discounted prices
controlling shipping
controlled shipping and exclusive early
access
uh love your butt and get the membership
mandy said did now do they have specific
underwear for all of these people
all of these groups mental health people
well-being women's rights
they must you know do they have like the
uh
the women's right fist on one of the
butt cheeks that they stole from black
power
right do they got that on there um
or does it just say it's harder for me
around the band
[Laughter]
sorry all right i'm having fun with this
one
um it's me undies everybody what do you
want you want a giant [ __ ] moose
right where your dick is
these guys can make it for you i'm sure
they have that one out there
um styles okay i've already read all of
that me undies has a great offer for my
listeners
for any first-time purchasers you get 15
off
and free shipping biandi's also has
their problem free philosophy if you're
not satisfied with any
product for any reason they'll refund it
or exchange it
no caveats no questions uh to get your
off your first order and free shipping
go to meundies.com
that's meundies.com oh look who it is
hello
fresh look at you
hello fresh offers convenient delivery
right to your doorstep for easy home
cooking with the family
the recipes are easy to follow and quick
to make with simple steps
and pictures to guide you along the way
hello fresh
hello newman hello hello fresh cuts out
stressful meal planning and grocery
store trips so you can enjoy cooking
and get dinner on the table in about 30
minutes or even less
you can save 40 percent by using hello
fresh versus shopping at your local
grocery store
and it's more convenient too there's
something for everyone including low
calorie
veggie vegetarian and kid-friendly
recipes
we enjoyed our box all of the recipes
were easy to follow and extremely
satisfying yeah they sent it to us when
we were in new york we had a great time
with it
hello fresh delivers fresh high quality
pre-portioned ingredients so you can
make
meals that are delicious and nutritious
hello fresh
streamlined supply chains means uh
produce gets to you faster and fresher
than the grocery store
i'm feeding the whole family has never
been easier with larger boxes
box sizes for more servings and more
savings hello fresh donated 2.5 million
meals to charity in 2019
and this year they're stepping up food
donations to local communities amid the
corona
virus crisis that's great um all right
go to hellofresh.com
bill burr and use the code bill burr to
get
you got the wrong code here this says
billbert80
and use the code well just use this code
and use code billbird80
to get a total of eighty dollars off
across five boxes including free
shipping on your first box or maybe i
[ __ ] this up on billbert
i think this is the right code that's
hellofresh.com billbert80
um and use the code billbert80 to get a
total of eighty dollars off
uh across five boxes including free
shipping on your first box
we got two more left we got two more
left
um indochino
uh talk about how you feel when you find
clothing that fits you right
well if i'm not a fat bastard i love how
it feels
you know but i actually respect clothes
that let me know how much weight i need
to lose to
you know you know that deal where you
got both your pecs are peeking out
you know so you're looking good but once
your belly becomes the third pec
then you just look like a man titted
douche you know that's why i like
clothes that fit me
and i never go i never move up in sizes
i just walk around
with my t-shirt riding up my back my
pants [ __ ] sliding down until i get
back in shape again that's how you do it
indochino's suits are great for weddings
and work and they even offer casual
options like shirts
coats and chinos share any recent or
upcoming occasion
you plan to dress up for
well you know i went to church on sunday
i could have used an indochino suit for
that
although because it was outside i really
felt a lot of people were dressing down
you know i saw somebody there was
wearing you know those you know those
sweatpants they call them vented sweat
vented sweatpants with the mesh on the
side so your legs can breathe more
you know what i mean what they really
are is just another way for women to try
to look even hotter when they're at the
gym
and then be like are you staring at my
legs
oh you mean you're you're [ __ ] uh
david lee roth [ __ ] pants that you
have on there
the [ __ ] your assless chaps that
you're wearing i mean like how much
more i don't know maybe if you just wore
the old school pet
sweatpants your [ __ ] legs could
breathe i don't know
then again jesus walked around barefoot
so who cares all right plowing ahead
here
uh with indochino you get to you get
custom fitted suits
coats and casual wear at surprisingly
affordable prices
customize everything from the fabric and
lining to the lapel
shape and monogram and since your order
is made
to your exact measurements it always
fits you perfectly if you're getting
married indochino
is a no-brainer for you and your
groomsmen absolutely you look sharp for
a [ __ ] great party
price forget off-the-rack suits that
don't fit different type
different body types indochino gives
everyone a tailored fit
uh order with ease and get it shipped
fast no matter where you live
and with all the ways to customize you
can add a personal touch
everyone will be proud of to wear there
you go for the wedding huh
you're right you write something on the
inside of lapel you get stitched in
there all the groomsmen
don't do what i'm about to do um
congratulations to me anyways
without emptying their pockets the best
part is indochino suits start at just
299.
with all customizations included visit
one of the indochino showrooms across
north america
or book a virtual appointment at and
shop online at indochino.com
and right now you'll get a 30 you'll get
30 off
any purchase of 399 or more when you
enter the code bur burr at checkout
that's indochino indochino.com
promo code burr um
i mean you look good for [ __ ] 300
bucks you can't beat that you know
um 300 suits the kind of suit you can
get into a fight and
just hoes it off all right my bookie
hey my bookie i [ __ ] you doing ever
since i started out
uh ever since i started out people have
been asking me for advice on all kinds
of things
but in covering sports it's usually
about who's going to win
and what team they should bet on is this
supposed to be me talking
uh you got the patriots of the 49ers
this week but i didn't even talk about
that i watched the patriots get the [ __ ]
kicked out of them by the 49ers
um yep it's been a tough year but i got
to tell you i love the patriots uniforms
and i'm going to keep watching them
because i love them
i love i love the pets i love the pats
we're going to get through this we're
going to get
[ __ ] get through covid next year
we'll have a better team i just
just need to protect cam newton that's
all all right you got the patriots or
49ers this week bucks or raiders well
the best piece of advice i can give any
give to anyone is
where you're betting is just as
important as who
you're betting on absolutely it's why i
always tell people to visit my bookie
they deposit
they deposit matt they've got deposit
matches sorry
yeah your local book he doesn't have
this [ __ ] free bets and huge cash prize
contests for you to take advantage of
all
season long nfl action check college
ball
bam plus they have a mobile friendly
website
and top of the line custom customer
service making their platform a one-stop
shop for all your betting needs
my bookie offers action on everything
from championship futures
to nfl in-game live betting making sure
you're covered every step of the way
congrats if you were one of the ones to
cash in on the generous
early season odds on the lakers to win
the nba championship sign up
i wish i jumped on that sign up at my
bookie today and when you do
use our promo code burr burr to claim
deposit
to claim a deposit match dollar for
dollar all the way up to a thousand
bucks
put a thousand dollars in until they're
gonna match you in case you don't
understand english
it's a bonus designed to give you a
little help and a head start on your
winning season
that's promo code burr burr for you to
claim your bonus
when you make your deposit stacked ufc
cards
presidential prop bets all the major
sports and more await you sign up today
to begin your winning season exclusively
at my bookie
all right there you go that's it for the
reads
um speaking of voting you know
one of the hardest things is those
[ __ ] props
you know prop this prop that
it's like if you vote yes on prop 62
uh you know busloads of children will be
bus to wonderful schools with computers
and then there'll be somebody like
will be like if you vote yes
um i can't get kidney dialysis and i'm
going to die
just like what the [ __ ] do i do here i
want the kids to get to school to a
great school but i don't want this
person to die
or do i i don't want them to but like
there's too many people so i got to go
with the kids
i got to go with the kids you know
a no vote on this means that but a yes
vote's going to make this happen
why can't they just i don't know
why can't they just tell you what's
gonna happen so i just i just defer to
my friends who are way more into
politics i call up my buddy jimmy dore i
ask him what's going on here
he gives me some advice you know i get a
little sage advice i call them my
bookies are [ __ ] the prop questions
um all right let's get into the uh what
are we here we got like
45 minutes in let's get into some of the
questions here
as i read them off of my phone i gotta
tell you something i have really good
looking kids thank god i married a
beauty
you know all i did was lighten them up
god damn they're good-looking kids every
time i turn on my phone i can't believe
those are my kids
um all right here we go i listened okay
here we go
i listened to 12 years of mmp in six
months what
hey billy legs is white as mozzarell
uh burr i'm a 23 23 year old guy from
egypt
dude what's going on other side of the
world
can i crash at your pad and i'll go look
at the pyramids
hey does anybody in egypt go and look at
the pyramids or is that like going to
[ __ ]
times square i bet if you live in egypt
every time one of your friends comes to
visit it's like
all right let's go ride a [ __ ] camel
and go over to the goddamn
[ __ ] pyramids jesus
christ you know and then when you can
actually take him to like the cool part
of cairo
i don't even know where the pyramids are
i know they're in egypt though
um i am a 23 year old guy from egypt and
arguably your biggest fan
in this part of the world well yeah i
don't think you have a lot of
competition
i would like to thank you for your help
throughout one of the roughest patches
of my short life
i graduated last spring for my college
as an architect
that's amazing that's a really cool job
by the way
being an architect designing that i love
i love the combination
of like when science meets like
art at the same time that's what i like
about uh
watching people like customize anything
or
build cars or design buildings and [ __ ]
i think it's amazing so congratulations
to you you must be a really talented
person
let's get to the tough part of your life
my last semester was spent during the
pandemic
and i spent all of it at home uh it was
a six
six month long semester which included
the most important part of my degree
a part that requires hours upon hours of
work
i would imagine you're designing
buildings people are going to be in them
and you don't want them to collapse i
would imagine that that is quite
a skill to learn you wouldn't want me
designing it
i basically worked myself into a zombie
the average workday throughout this
period was 18 hours
in front of a computer screen or until
my eyes started to twitch
or my hands start to shake
um you know you can get those blue
glasses blue tinted glasses
to look at computer screens it's a
little late to tell you that but in the
future
if you further your studies i heard that
those things work
and to make it works i couldn't go to
the gym or work
with a friend due to the pandemic and my
only friend
during these terrible nights was you oh
jesus
oh my god all right your podcast was
always playing in the background of my
computer i went through 12 years of the
mm
podcast in six miserable months and it
was the only thing that would make me
smile or laugh
jesus christ you could actually learn
how to be an architect with my dumb ass
talking in the background that's amazing
i know this sounds horrible but on the
bright side i finished this semester
with the 4.0
gpa because you put the [ __ ] work in
you didn't whine about it you got down
to when you got it done good for you
that's inspiring and graduate top of my
class and got a scholarship for my
master's degree
and i wouldn't be kissing your pale ass
if i told you
that i couldn't have done that without
your podcast look at that
look at the juxtaposition of the smart
thing he's doing versus the
ignorance of this podcast it all comes
together
um i remember several nights when i had
no more fighting me and i wanted to
sleep so bad
but i just kept telling myself just play
some clips from the mm podcast and
push through the night dude this is
starting to feel like a paid ad this
guy's kissing my ass so much
i hope this makes it to the podcast so i
can hear you read it
and so that maybe 20 years from now one
of your kids may stumble upon it on
youtube
and know that their old freckle [ __ ] of
but dad helped out a guy he doesn't know
in a country he probably
can't point to on a map what are you
talking about
i like that you trashed me in the end i
know where it is it's right there on
uh the northeast of uh
of africa and then you got the
uh the little canal there you had the
six day war with israel anwar
sadat was one of my favorite world
leaders
and i hated when he got he got
assassinated i know a little bit about
that over there
what is that not the red sea what i used
to know the name of that um
that little channel there because back
in the day you'd have to sail all the
way around
all the [ __ ] way around um
see i'm not that bad isn't algerian
libya
is all up there for all you guys know
i'm looking on a map now but i'm not
i'm kind of into geography i was doing
this thing for a while i wanted to learn
every single country
and then i discovered how difficult that
was and i didn't stick with it but this
guy did
and now he's a [ __ ] architect and he
got a he got a [ __ ]
what did he get uh he got a scholarship
for his master's degree
that's amazing can you imagine the
podcast studio this guy could design
all right halloween advice oh oh wait a
second wait a second wait a second
come on play it
[Music]
hey that's me
somebody else all right it's time for
advice
on halloween halloween advice okay well
how can you have halloween we're all
well i guess because we're all wearing
masks it's safe
where i got to throw the candy at the
kids this year come on people is this
microphone on
all right here we go hi bill
hello person uh hope you and the family
are doing well i am in need of your
advice on a con
controversial subject and who better
than you
i have a few nephews ages 2 to 12 years
old
that are into superheroes one of my
nephews is about four to five years old
and wants to be black panther for
halloween
he's inspired by the story and likes the
character my sister-in-law wants to get
him a costume
but her white friends are telling her
that she cannot have her son
as black panther because he's white
well do they have like well wait a
second what what sort of mask
does he wait a second
that's hilarious that's hilarious wait
is it just a suit
and then his white face sticks out the
front and then you got to put him in
you're not going to put don't put him in
whatever it is
do not go blackface on this one please
white people
for the love of god um
all right my nephew does not understand
racism nor
truly understands why someone would
discriminate against someone else's
based on the color of their skin it
almost seems wrong to tell a child you
cannot be a character based on their
skin should my nephew
be black panther on a for halloween yeah
if it's just the costume i would do that
all right i would don't try to make
don't do the blackface thing with his
face okay
is this whitewashing or racist just
want to make sure myself and my family
are not ignorant to any racist
actions all right and who better to ask
but a [ __ ] white guy on this one wait
let's see black
panther i'm gonna see what this costume
looks the first one
halloween god damn it not galloween
halloween halloween
costume all right if it's just his face
pointing out i don't see why he can't do
it
oh what a surprise look at this it's
it's not gonna load
this internet that i [ __ ] pay a
million dollars for you [ __ ] [ __ ]
let's go
all right i'll it won't pull up so
here's the deal
yeah if it's just like
you know if it's just like a [ __ ]
like an iron man costume i gotta be
honest with you i saw black panther i
can't remember them i can't remember
movies i don't know what it is i see him
and i just immediately forget him
i imagine his face had to be obscured
somehow
you know some sort of mask or something
i just just put your white kid in this
in the costume and that's it just don't
put any [ __ ]
blackface [ __ ] on his face and you
should be fine
i think you should be fine i think uh if
that's all you're doing then i think
your white friends
are wrong um but what you should do is
ask one of your black friends
and when they're done laughing i'm sure
they'll give you an answer all right
marrying stepsister
been through the same all right billy no
shoulders i like that one by the way
billy no shoulders
is up to [ __ ] three pounders 11 reps
no pain no pain whatsoever
i'm cruising along here i figure once i
just need to uh just keep doing this get
up to about 10 11 12 pounds
and it's gonna be pull up time again for
me um
all right if i could just somehow get to
a lat pull-down machine somewhere during
this [ __ ] pandemic
billy no shoulders you had a listener
email in on
monday the 19th about a guy
um about to marry his stepsister this
also happened to me when i was 20. jesus
christ who knew that this was like a
[ __ ] thing
i've been going out with my high school
girlfriend for a few years
one day her dad had dropped off it
dropped her off at my mom's house
wait okay so just a refresh
uh people who didn't listen to last
podcast this guy was dating this chick
and his dad ended up marrying
his girlfriend's mother
they were both single obviously and they
hit it off they got married
while he was still dating this chick so
his girlfriend then became legally his
stepsister
um okay so this person is saying this
also happened to me
one day her dad had dropped off
dropped her off at my mom's house where
i was living at the time
no issues with this or so i thought over
the next few weeks he started
to drop her off more and more being
young and ignorant i didn't think
anything of it
until the day came when they my mom and
her dad
sat my girlfriend and i down to tell us
they were now an item
and that he would be moving in oh my god
to say that my mom is a selfish [ __ ]
would be an understatement every one of
her friends her family and even my dad
her ex-husband tried to tell her this
was a [ __ ] up situation
but she was having none of it no more
than a month of him moving in
they broke the news to us that they were
getting married
imagine marrying a guy you've known for
the
best part of three months you can see
how this is going to end
well it seemed to work back in the day
but then again people just didn't
believe in divorce
um anyways he put the s
on it thank you anyway my girlfriend and
i broke up because of this situation
then things became more [ __ ] up
when my now ex-girlfriend's mother
kicked her out of the house
and guess where she had to come and live
you guessed it with us
now i'm getting confused i told my mom
that i wouldn't be going to the wedding
and that this entire situation was going
to take a toll on my relationship with
her
to which she replied if you don't like
it go and live with your dad
so i did my mom and her new
husband-to-be
went and bought a house together and got
married i stood by my
i stood my ground and didn't go to the
wedding
[ __ ] them the marriage lasted two months
wow i'm now 29 and haven't had a
relationship with my mom
since [ __ ] her anyways hope you and the
family stay safe stop blowing out your
shoulders
lifting up a pint of water you bald
[ __ ]
uh thanks and get [ __ ] um
this person's a fellow private pilot and
a drummer
drum lover from scotland all right yeah
[ __ ] drum loving
[ __ ] um
well she is your mother so it's some day
someday you're gonna have to patch it up
but
uh wow
what a whirlwind of [ __ ] that was and
the fact that it just lasted
i got to commend you for not just
showing up being like hey what did i say
i do it i called it and given her all
kinds of [ __ ]
um you know at some point
you just have to understand that your
parents are human
you know what that doesn't work with
this yeah you got a nut job for a mom i
don't know what to tell you
uh but she is your mom so at some point
you know if you don't like it go live
with your dad
wow wow
i i my advice to you i would just i
would
try to find the humor in it and i would
just
i wouldn't let it go for a long time but
i wouldn't be nasty about it i would
just be making jokes
just be like hey mom you know i uh i got
a new job do you want to come down and
start [ __ ] my boss and maybe marry
him
and then two two days later divorce him
[Laughter]
i don't know i would just do that i mean
what else can you do
um but i will tell you this don't
[ __ ] turn to alcohol to [ __ ]
help it all right because that'll be a
whole other problem and you'll end up
having a two-month marriage also
all right where to move to hey bill
bilbo naggins here's the top five states
to live in
one new hampshire lowest crime rate
poverty rate and pollution levels in the
country
great scenery and very few people health
system is one of the best in the country
and schools are exceptional
no state income tax or sales tax and not
to mention it's close to massachusetts
minnesota i know you love lakes and here
you can buy the cheapest waterfront
property with more than 11 000 lakes i
love minnesota
it's just cold as [ __ ] uh both global
warming who knows
third safest state with excellent
schools and fourth lowest poverty rate
however very cold in the winter i mean
minus 30 degrees all right that's out
idaho i can't go idaho that's where
every hollywood douche ends up going
uh it's in the it's in the middle so you
won't have to spend a lot of time in
planes very low crime and good
yeah but i'll have to have a lot of
connecting flights in good schools and
very beautiful but
costs of houses are rising because most
californians are moving here yes
uh houston austin texas i am not doing
texas
texas had a biblical level [ __ ]
drought a few years ago and you have
fires just like la
and hurricanes so i'm just substituting
earthquakes for hurricanes
surprisingly liberal with low taxes you
can contact your friends there about the
level of racism
good schools but not good health care
system five ohio
i love ohio uh you can move next door to
dave
he can tell you about ohio especially
the experiences of people
of color uh buh-bye and good luck but we
know you aren't moving now i'm not
[ __ ] moving
i'm not moving um
i actually think i'm gonna stick it out
here and watch la go down to the [ __ ]
population it should be
be able to cruise around um
all right abusive girlfriend hey
billy the baggy balls burr i'm a 23 year
old from malaysia hey
i like the internationals this is great
knowing people are listening you're
all the way in malaysia you're listening
to this it's amazing
uh yes i can't find malaysia it's down
in the south uh the south pacific right
down near the philippines right
singapore and all over there right i've
been to my with my
girlfriend for over a year she was fun
and pleasant for the first six months of
our lives
probably hot i feel like every chick
down there is like every chick in like
the philippines malaysia
singapore they're all beautiful um
she was fun and pleasant for the first
six months of our relationship
i quit my job at our national border
which is three hours
from where she lives uh
things were wonderful until i lost my
hair from radiotherapy
for my acoustic neuroma
acoustic neuroma second i hear acoustic
i'm thinking guitar
i don't know what that is she started
getting verbally abusive and calling me
names like
ugly naked mole rat holy [ __ ]
she threatened to murder me anytime she
would think i would
[ __ ] up and she'd get angry any time i
made
small a small mistake like turning into
a wrong alley
i say sorry now more than i say i love
her
yeah dude dump this [ __ ] douche
i would just lower myself just to avoid
arguing
getting into arguments yeah buddy you're
in an abusive relationship
you need to get some self-esteem and get
out of this thing
and don't even think because of what you
went through no other you're not going
to get another woman you are and you're
going to get someone who's actually a
[ __ ] human being other than this
[ __ ] [ __ ]
in the last three months she just
started to get physical she justified
her actions by saying that she came from
a broken home
her dad left and her mom were barely
home they live with her stepdad now and
things are okay at home and they all
like me whenever
i tried to break up with her she always
says that she would kill herself if i
ever left well that's her [ __ ] fault
i don't want that baggage to be put on
me uh what do you think i should do
apologies for the bad grammar your
grammar's been great big fan
thank you and go [ __ ] yourself uh you
should break up with her
you should break up with her you should
absolutely break up with her 100 [ __ ]
percent her [ __ ] suicidal [ __ ]
is not your problem and she's calling
you a naked mole rat and getting
physical with you and she has all these
[ __ ] excuses do you want to stay with
this broad it's got to be like look
uh you got to go to therapy and fix
yourself for i'm leaving all right
dude [ __ ] that [ __ ] that
i would just i would [ __ ] and i would
just this is like poker
i would just match what she's saying
you know if you leave me i'll kill
myself all right if i stay in this
relationship with you i'm gonna kill
myself
so what should i do
if you leave i'm gonna kill myself what
are you [ __ ] reading shakespeare
grow up go go [ __ ] [ __ ] be an
[ __ ] to some new guy
um if you want to go passive aggressive
you could just
stop apologizing how about this
how about you stop apologizing and then
she gets so mad she breaks up with now
you're playing a game
you can't ballistic i'm not trying to
belittle the fact that she's saying
she's suicidal
but um i kind of lost any sort of
empathy for when she said what she said
about you considering what you were
going through
with your acoustic guitar uh cancer
there whatever the [ __ ] it is
uh all right top five stupid questions
yeah break up with the dude
break up with her go find a woman in
your dreams and live your [ __ ] life
instead of being held emotionally
hostage by this lunatic
and thank you for listening listening
listening
over there in malaysia shout out to
everybody in malaysia except for that
[ __ ] [ __ ]
all right top five stupid questions uh
from a lawyer oh this is this is a new
segment if you work with the general
public we have the top
five stupid questions and i'm guilty of
it
i went to joshua tree and i asked the
park ranger
where is the joshua tree all right so
i'm not looking down on anybody but i do
love reading these
all right hello bill i have worked in
the legal field
just picturing that park ranger's face
when he was looking at me like is this
guy [ __ ] with me
and then the realization that i was
serious and his in
and then which slowly turned into
excitement on his face that he had a
story to tell his friend his
fellow co-workers all right hello bill
i have worked in the legal field what is
that thing i just went to inhale
through my mouth and then all of a
sudden it's like you know somebody
pulled the choke on you
i don't know what that is all right i've
worked in the legal field in various
capacities throughout the last six years
uh from investigating sex crimes oh
jesus
to transporting federal prisoners to
being in many courtrooms my experience
uh my experiences have not lacked any
excitement or stupid questions
all right number one i was reading off
my first warrant i ever
served in a county jail this warrant was
for a battery charge
and she was in solitary confinement
during this time
the young girl asks so does this mean i
i can't go home right now
that's [ __ ] hilarious you're being
charged with
hitting an old woman over the head with
a safe
so like does that mean i can't go home
right now oh jesus
um while investigating a sex crime
oh boy
the person who is believed to be
extremely guilty of committing
several crimes at a daycare admitted
many of these atrocities to the police
on tape
when i asked him about the question he
says
does this look bad oh boy
he admitted to doing that at a day care
center like dude
they should just take that guy out back
and once they try him and convict him
and just shoot him in the [ __ ] head
i i have no sex offenders that's that's
it it's over it's a wrap
see you don't need you
number three while in federal court
a re-sentencing hearing was taking place
for a man
who had been in prison for seven years
for production of meth
an intern sitting next to me while the
man was in shackles in a prison uniform
actually asked me is he under arrest
wow dude these are great during my first
autopsy i thought you were a lawyer
a sheriff deputy asked me
so do we just throw the whole body away
when we're done
oh my god
oh my god i mean and that guy has a gun
right he had a gun on his hip and he
said that all right
all right okay number five following
a court hearing where a mother who was
high on meth
a family court hearing and the mother is
high on meth i mean that alone
the mother's parental rights were
terminated the mother asked the judge
when do i bring my daughter back for the
next court thing
[Music]
god thank you bill for bringing many
much needed laughs for me during the
week
also best to you nia and the two little
birds oh wow
jesus christ that's such a great segment
you guys are
really writing in a bunch of killer
stuff um
speaking of which my daughter made my
son
laugh for the second time my son has
laughed twice in his short little cute
life and she's made him laugh both times
they absolutely love each other
and um he was laying on his belly
and he's really like coordinated
and um he's already like
figuring out how to crawl
he's absolutely the most adorable little
baby boy i've ever seen in my life
so she does this thing where she was
just doing like you know
blowing on his back making the fart
noises and he just thought it was
hilarious he was doing those squeals and
everything
and she started cracking up laughing and
he laughed too
and i got it all on video it's the
greatest thing ever
and um i don't know we've been having
the best time we just been having the
best time so
um i made some pumpkin bread last night
because i'm a holiday guy dooby dooby
doo
and somehow i [ __ ] it up i don't think
i put enough sugar in it
um but anyway i um
i'm totally i gotta figure out how we're
gonna do the halloween thing
with my daughter um
i'm thinking me and my wife
maybe can just be in different rooms
bedrooms and she can just keep going
back and forth knocking i'll just have
different hats and act like i'm
different people until we fill up her
candy or something we'll have to do
something
she gets it because everybody's sick she
gets it but um
she already has her costume picked out
she's getting excited and stuff so it's
kind of going to suck
like most people you gotta tell your
kids uh there's no halloween this year
but something that they'll get to guilt
their kids about you should be happy
i remember when i was a kid one year
they canceled halloween
sorry all right um my voice held up here
sorry for the low energy podcast
um that is it i don't know who's playing
monday night football i didn't even talk
about the seattle arizona cardinal game
was [ __ ] incredible and i gotta tell
you something
i think russell wilson i know they lost
at everything but i
i don't think i've ever seen a guy
you know i've seen throughout the years
great quarterbacks make difficult throws
but i've just nev
this guy makes the hardest [ __ ]
throws he makes him look like a screen
pass
like he's just dumping it off to a
running back that touchdown that they
got
um that i thought was the dagger
and was gonna put um arizona
down for the count at the back of the
end zone
who's basically like the montana clark
he just every [ __ ] time
like i don't care if the guy's [ __ ]
10 yards away
or 40 50 yards down the field i've just
never seen a guy just put the ball
right right over the defender and right
on his receiver's fingertips
the guy is he's one of the greatest
quarterbacks of all time forget about
now they're talking about him being an
mvp
that guy is [ __ ] unbelievable and
having said that the arizona cardinals
are fun as hell to watch
i hope kenyon drake is not hurt i hope
he gets healthy
um but even then they had some other kid
step
in for him and he ran for a bunch of
yards but that is an exciting [ __ ]
team to watch
and they have sucked so many years
more than they've they've been good i
know they had that one time when they
went to the super bowl there with larry
fitzgerald and kurt warner
that was a great one i think that was
against the steelers i believe
but um that is a fun team to watch so
i'm having a blast as much as my team is
is struggling
i'm really having fun watching it this
year and i know that i know my pats are
going to be you know
you know we had some guys opt out
because of covet or whatever we're
learning a new system
who knows maybe we'll get some good
draft picks bill belichick with some
good draft picks that's
that's a nice i like that scenario so uh
we shall see what happens um
all right that's it i will talk to you
guys later
have a great couple of days go [ __ ]
yourselves and i'll check in on you on
thursday
you